this is a very emotional scene but now
he has just lost her game and you are
not particularly aware of her emotional
state so you sort of moronically bumble
up onto the rooftop ignoring her state
of mind which is a bit of as you think
it's gonna be great
existential malaise for you ma'am
existential malaise ganas but you're
ready to party believe me don't have a
game anymore I mean like what am I gonna
do all day come on are you kidding you
sleep in you do no work then you go to
tappers with me every night I've
literally just described paradise but I
loved my game so they've decided they're
going to go to the Internet to fix that
the steering wheel on Penelope's game
and they're gonna get a new replacement
one at eBay so this is the scene in
which they enter into the the Wi-Fi
router for the first time it's a sweet
echo check this out so we find vanilla
bean kind of out on the street of the
internet at this puddle of water and
she's trying to coax this this song to
come out that the princesses have
promised that every princess has inside
of them reflecting what is it that I
want okay what is that I want what is my
quest Wow like I can't believe it I get
to go I get to go home so uh alright I
guess that's it I guess I just I just
wanted a steering wheel and now I got it
so woohoo
slotter race excellent really good i
think that's yeah we got it
I mean I mean one takes government
that's what we call it why don't we jump
to death 9:12 okay this is Ralph kind of
struggling not to look at the little
brother but explain why he's there ah
the reason I came to your neck of the
face ah I mean there's a face in your
neck ah
I mean woods neck of the woods the
reason I'm here is because I well I
heard a little tumor I rumor I heard a
rumor well you could give me kind of a
harmless virus kind of thing that might
be able to slow down the slaughter race
game okay this man is on fire literal
and figurative fire but he still needs
200 million hearts in the next five
hours or this beautiful child loses her
cane that's why I'm on to Phase two and
you might pop up on me I need you out
there puffing up and getting clicks all
over the Internet I'm talking tumblr
Instagram Mashable be my Pied Pipers and
leave that beautiful traffic to buzz too
because wrecking Ralph needs your hearts
yo Ralph you in here dude hey I gotta
show you
Oh Ralph first rule of the Internet do
not read the comments I should have told
you that look this place can bring out
the worst in some people but you gotta
ignore all this this isn't about you
Ralph it's about them congratulations
all you did it
what really yes check your fuzzy account
you needed 27k you got over 30 grand oh
my gosh this is great thank you yes I
couldn't have done it without you that's
really true Deebo Thanks
say why write the dance does they're
right over right yes or played out the
big enough coming from Thank You mr.
nose marshalling oh you're welcome
it's the link redirecting to eBay in the
car forums and it's gonna slip inside of
it